let's go back to discord and hear from a
few more people it's great to hear from
people in the audience particularly on a
day like today let's go to clark from
portland now is that portland maine or
portland oregon my friend
that's portland oregon oh okay yeah i
was i was actually just hopped in the
phone call so i didn't get a time to ask
her think of a question oh no um so just
send to someone else real quick oh my
god well can i ask you a question
absolutely are you familiar with hood
river
yeah i love hood river actually i i'm
i'm potentially scheduled to go to a
wedding there next year is this a place
i would enjoy you think
it's beautiful i'll tell you what it's
um it's kind of right in between it's
it's in the cascade gorge okay so it's
right in between the high desert and
kind of the coastal range and so it's a
really nice mix of temperate climate and
a more arid climate
yeah gorgeous sound pretty good i would
i'm looking forward to that then all
right well good clark you think of a
question okay all right have a good one
david all right very good there's clark
from portland who did not have a
question but at least was able to answer
a little something for me let's go next
to mark from stockholm
mark welcome
hey am i am i good you are are you
swedish or are you an american in sweden
uh i am swedish actually beautiful i'm
not shocked to hear your perfect english
thank you
um yo yes get over anyway um so despite
my okay i hope that wasn't some horribly
racist statement no no i i just said no
no i just said like i'm swedish i
promise okay very good i'm very good
um i wouldn't do that but um so like
despite you know my tone of voice i
actually do have like a really serious
question that i don't know if you feel
equipped to answer this but i'm just
gonna take a shot in the dark now okay
um so recently like you know myself i'm
like a libertarian socialist my mom
is
like leaning heavily towards like the
christian white nationalist far right
really and
yeah and i have like no idea how to
tackle this i don't know if i should be
you know if i should stand up for myself
because the thing is too like i came out
as pansexual to her and she's totally
just like
dismissive and rude about it despite the
fact that prior to this prior to
recently she actually was a pretty like
liberal-leaning person
so if i understand correctly
your mom is a swedish white nationalist
and you i'm not going to hold on
then you can correct it and you are
a swedish libertarian socialist
pansexual and there's conflict now
yes wow um
that's a big matzo ball hanging out
there
i just want to like make it clear like
you know i'm not going to label her or
anything i'm just saying that like she's
leaning heavily towards that i don't
know definitively what she would
identify as is that a big is that a
common movement in sweden because sweden
is has the stereotype of being so social
democracy left-wing you know
yeah well i'll put it this way so like
the the stereotype it actually adds feel
to the fire for a lot of like far-right
movements in sweden there actually is
like a major like pretty like far right
party in government right now yeah the
sweden democrats
um you know like they've
definitely um cannot like served the way
if you whatever like you know they
basically basically like benefited
greatly from this um huge
influx of people
you know looking at immigration and
saying like hey you know we're taking in
too many people
you know they look around like you know
people have even like posted pictures on
like swedish um subreddits and [ __ ] it's
like
you know it's like a picture okay now
let's watch the language because then
we're gonna have to bleep it pat please
make it all right i'm not gonna need it
i'm not gonna say anything oh i thought
you just dropped an s-bomb did you not
just drop an s-bomb oh
no no no now you dropped another one
okay all right everybody let's uh
let's see if we can get away from this i
have no advice about the mom thing okay
question remind me what pansexual is
so pansexual is essentially this idea
that i'm not limited to
gender when it comes to attraction so
like i found
uh men women non-binary people
attractive that's basically the gist of
it and by the way sorry for like cursing
it's a force of habit i'll try not to do
it no that's okay so basically pansexual
it's sort of like a whatever sexual any
adult
exactly got it it's got it it's like if
i find somebody attractive they're
attractive no matter what their gender
identity is beautiful all right well i
appreciate the call and the insights and
by the way
do you speak english with some of your
swedish friends like how do you speak
english so well it's so common in sweden
i i make youtube videos and i listen to
a lot of comedians from the
that's about it got it got it hey and by
the way this and we're now getting off
topic it is interesting
that in sweden
everybody
speaks american english like you would
think being so close to the uk you might
everybody there might learn british
english but it's not the case
you would you would think and also i i
was taught like the uk version of
english in school but i never
jived with it so i just kind of like
went along with like standard like
northern american english got it got it
all right very good well i really
appreciate the call and your insights
yeah no problem thanks for having me
here we go
wow mark from stockholm really i mean
saying it all saying it all
and only two bleeps necessary